guns when guns were first invented they
called them the great equalizer who were
they good for who were they bad for
well this is one of the these places
where I have uh changed my perspective I
long believed the second amendment was
the greatest error in our constitution I
no longer believe that and that doesn't
mean that I look past all of the
terrible unnecessary Carnage that arises
because guns are easily available but
I'm watching
tyranny erupt in places that I never
would have expected it and I am
wondering if the founders did not very
wisely understand that this day would
come and that it will be very hard for
tyrants to
succeed in America if the populace
is armed so again I don't I don't I know
people will hear something in that that
I'm not saying the cost of having these
weapons commonly available is huge and
frankly completely unacceptable to me
really so the costs are so you're you
went from pro-second amendment to now
saying it would be better if we didn't
have guns no no the other way I'll say
yeah so now the benefit of having it is
good versus not happening even though I
appreciate the tremendous unnecessary
cost of these weapons being common right
even though I see that cost I believe
nothing is will be more destruct
than if tyranny I mean we've already
seen lots of hints of tyranny in in
recent times in the U.S but if tyranny
takes over
our our nation and the West yeah we are
in even more serious trouble so I
believe the harms that do come from
these weapons being common will be
dwarfed by the harms of uh things like
what we've you know what we saw in the
20th century in the Soviet Union for
example so let's go back right now in
Iran yeah so let's go back to the
question so uh who the invention of gun
the great equalizer who did it hurt who
did it benefit
foreign
I think I don't want to pretend to be an
expert on that question it would take me
a lot of thought to to get to an answer
right I believe this is this is what
happens when you ask a former professor
of evolutionary very rarely very rarely
do I have an answer more than a
evolutionary biology scientist okay but
who did it hurt and who did it benefit I
think who it hurt the most were bullies
right people that could just strong arm
you physically or in any capacity and
who did it help it helped weaker people
sometimes you might say the weaker sex
it helped women
um I think at the end of the day if if
there's two very strong people a man and
a woman or a weaker man and a very
strong man yeah and all of a sudden the
weaker person has a gun
essentially that's the great equalizer
so I think it hurt bullies the most and
if you extrapolate that to governments
and you take a look at you know bully
governments whether it's Iran today with
the moolahs whether it's in Venezuela
where you don't can't have a gun or any
place where the you know Society or the
uh civilization or the people don't have
a weapon to defend themselves you're
going to be at the whim of tyrannical
governments and Bullies so to answer
your question I think it helped weaker
people defend themselves all right but I
want to I want to push back slightly no
no I'm way smarter than you and I
here's I I believe your argument is
correct as far as it goes and the
question is is it correct in the end
right you can take that same argument
and you could apply it to nuclear
weapons and you could say actually what
we want to do is have every country be
armed with nuclear weapons because then
big countries won't bully small
countries
if you did that
the nuclear war that we will ultimately
face will be that much sooner right
because you have that many itchy trigger
fingers that could initiate the thing
and so I'm not convinced that even I
mean look we saw
that nuclear weapons did
um produce peace it worked but in the
end is that their net effect we can't
measure that because we're not at the
end so I don't know within that effect
of Guns is I do believe the effect
you're describing is real and important
the only caveat that I would say I can't
believe I'm pushing back on you right
now is that the the capacity for these
nuclear weapons
in the wrong hands could literally end
Earth as we know it whereas a gun or an
M16 yes there could be some Carnage but
you're not literally blowing up the
world so nuclear weapons to a certain
extent is you know that threshold where
it's like don't cross that line Brad you
can't let a Playboy argue with you this
guy's resume it's just it's not you you
you're a former professor of
evolutionary biology he's a he's a form
of an evolutionary biology there is
biology there but it's difficult
it's a different thing let's go through
that let's go through that so okay so
guns specific guns not nuclear guns
benefited you know the average person's
like listen that guy's been bullying the
city this time he comes around hey you
can't do this anymore you got to get out
of my house okay [__] I'm not messing
with that family I'm out because they
got a gun fantastic right it's like when
you got the sign in a backyard beware
there's a uh German Shepherd and beware
and there's no dog but that sign itself
gets some people to say I don't want to
mess with that place and there's a study
showing that there's a percentage of
people that don't mess with a house that
just has that sign whether there is a
real dog or not it still helps you to
create some safety nuclear fine internet
you know a lot of people were worried
about internet at the beginning you have
radio you have TV you have all this
stuff right who did who did YouTube
scare who did the anchor or you know
Spotify uh benefit and hurt if you if we
think about who YouTube and Spotify and
these places hurt it hurt mainstream
media it scared the crap out of the
bullies that have been telling everybody
one side of the story now you got to sit
there and listen to the number one
podcast in the world Joe Rogan telling
you a different way because he's got a
guess that got you thinking now we're
going out there doing research going to
Google which at one point we were
concerned so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]